Çeviri: Sessenol Projesi
Gözden geçirme: Sessenol Projesi
Bana diyorlar ki; ya senin alışık olman
lazım niye bu kadar heyecanlısın?
Bu kadar seyirciye alışık değilim,
çünkü en son Eskişehir'de
gösteriye çıktık,
benzetmek gibi olmasın balkon vardı.
Balkon boş kaldı diye çamaşır astık.
Burada balkonda dolmuş
çok teşekkür ediyorum
zahmet edip geldiniz.
(Alkışlar)
Size iki cümle sonra bir şey söyleceğim
çok şaşıracaksınız.
Bir;
siz şimdi buraya yavaş hayat kavramını
dinlemek, belki öğrenmek,
belki öğrenip uygulamak için
zahmet edip geldiniz ve
üstüne para ödediniz.
Doğal olarak benden yavaş hayat kavramını
savunmamı bekliyorsunuz.
İki;
şimdi şaşıracağınız
cümleyi söylüyorum:
Ben yavaş hayat kavramına karşıyım.
(Gülüşmeler)
(Alkışlar)
Güldünüz gülün ben yine de karşıyım,
gerçekten karşıyım çünkü hayatın
yavaşı hızlısı yoktur, döngüsü vardır.
Güneş'in bir döngüsü vardır,
Dünya'nın bir döngüsü vardır,
mevsimlerin, iklimlerin,
göç eden kuşların, açan çiçeklerin,
kızaran domateslerin hepsinin
bir döngüsü vardır.
Siz ne yaparsanız yapın,
Dünya hep aynı hızda döner.
Mesela 2016 hepimiz için çok kötü geçti,
Dünya halimize acıyıp:
- Lan biraz hızlı döneyim de
sevinsin garibanlar, demedi, diyemez.
Ya da 2017 iyi başladı,
-ulan ileride ne olur ne olmaz
biraz ağırdan alayım, demez.
Bir domates asla acele etmez.
Siz bir domatesin acele ettiğini
hiç duydunuz mu?
Duyamazsınız.
Yahut domates dile gelse,
ki aslında çok korkunç bir fikir.
İlk diyeceği şey: -Yeme beni
yeme beni, olurdu herhalde.
Domates asla büyümek için acele etmez.
Yani şöyle; -ulan bir an evvel
büyüyeyim, kızarayım,
nefesimi tutayım da kızarayım demez.
Böyle saçmalıkları böyle aptallıkları
bir tek insan yapar, biz yaparız.
Niye?
Çünkü derler ki; öleceğini bilen
ve ömrünün kısa olduğunu bilen tek canlı,
insandır.
İnsan, öleceğini bilip üzülür.
Ömrünün kısa olduğunu da
bilir buna da üzülür
ve bu yüzden
hızlı yaşamak ister.
Bu yüzden o kısa ömrüne
çok şey sığdırmak ister.
Peki ama
sevdiğimiz şarkılar da var.
Dinliyoruz söylüyoruz, dinleyip söylerken
şarkı bitecek diye üzülüyor muyuz?
Yoksa şarkının tadını mı çıkartıyoruz?
Mesela;
Mozart’ın en ünlü eseri ülkemizde:
”Daha dün annemizin
kollarında yaşarken.”
Bunu çok seviyoruz bu şarkıyı diye
ağırdan alıyor muyuz?
Daha dün annemizin
veya -ulan bu kısa süreye
birkaç sevdiğim şarkıyı daha
söyleyeyim, diye
hızlı hızlı söylüyor muyuz bu şarkıyı?
-Daha dün annemizin kollarında yaşarken
çiçekli bahçemizin yollarında koşarken,
rapçi oldum ben o ye!
(Gülüşmeler)
Yapıyor muyuz?
Yapmıyoruz.
Niye?
Çünkü müziği müzik yapan,
o aradaki eslerdir.
Önemli bir şey söylüyorum,
müziği müzik yapan
ses değil sessizliktir.
Sessizlik olmayan müzik
gürültüden ibarettir.
O yüzden arada durmak
lazım arkadaşlar,
arada susmak lazım.
Bunlar, yani kişisel
subjektif görüşlerim değil,
size çok bilimsel bir
deneyle kanıtlayacağım.
Yani hızlı yaşarsak ne oluyor?
Bunu kanıtlayacağım,
arkamı dönmüyorum.
Şimdi.
Evet.
Bu bir çark.
Kapalı şunu açmamız lazım.
Şunu atayım.
Şimdi çark;
Newton çarkı ya da
renk çarkı da diyorlar
ama hazır bulamadığımız için
biz icat ettik, boyadık.
İşte; mavi, kırmızı, sarı.
Şimdi Newton bir deney yapmış.
Şimdi renkler
var döndürüyorsun,
beyaza dönüyor.
Newton'a sorarsan
bu deney;
beyazın bütün renklerden
oluştuğunu kanıtlıyor.
Bana sorarsanız;
ki bana soracaksınız Newton öldü.
(Gülüşmeler)
Yeni duyanlar için üzgünüm.
Başınız sağ olsun.
(Gülüşmeler)
Bana sorarsanız bu deney;
hızlı yaşarsak,
yani daha çok şey yaşamak için
hızlı yaşıyoruz ya, hızlı yaşarsak,
daha çok şey yaşamayız
hayatın renklerini kaçırırız,
hayatın renklerini ıskalarız.
Bakın bir daha şimdi;
renkler
yok.
Bilimsel olarak kanıtladım mı?
Altını çiziyorum, hızlı yaşarsanız
hayatı ıskalarsınız.
(Alkışlar)
Peki dedim,
ölümlü olduğunu bilen insan,
kısa ömrüne daha çok şey
sığdırmak için
hızlı yaşıyor, bir de ne yapıyor;
çok şey yaşamak istiyor.
Çok şey yaşamak istiyor.
Eskiden;
mesela tarım toplumunda,
yaşayacağı şeylerin sayısı belliydi.
Tohumu ekiyordu ve bekliyordu.
Yani hızlandırmasına gerek de yok
bir imkanda yok
yapacağı şeyler sınırlı.
Daha da eskiye gidelim; taş devrine.
Taş devrinde arkadaşlar,
insanının yapacağı şeyler
taşla sınırlıydı.
Hatta yani,
taşla bugün yapılacak
pek çok şeyi de yapamıyorlardı.
Mesela beştaş, okey oynamak falan.
Taşla sınırlıydı,
taşı kullanabiliyor
bir tek taşla bir şeyler yapabiliyordu.
O taşı yontabilmesi için
binlerce yıl geçti.
Sonra o yonttuğu taşı cilalamayı
akıl edip başarabilmesi için
yine binlerce yıl geçti.
Yani bir çağın açılması için
binlerce yıl beklememiz gerekiyordu.
Şimdi;
içinde bulunduğumuz çağın
pek çok adı var:
Hız çağı, internet çağı, atom çağı
uzay çağı.
Çağ, çağ, çağ, çağ...
Öyle bir hale geldik ki çağların biri
kapanmadan öbürü açılıyor. Bu açıldı
bu da hala açıldı, bu hala açık öbürü
açıldı, bütün çağlar açık kaldı.
Açık kalınca kurander yapıyor, cereyan
yapıyor arada kalıyor hasta oluyoruz,
üşütüyoruz.
(Alkışlar)
Şimdi insan daha çok şey
yaşayabilmek için daha çok icat ediyor
ama ihtiyaç fazlası
şeyler icat ediyor.
Şey gibi bu dükkanlar gibi
ihtiyaç fazlası ömürler, icatlar.
İhtiyaç fazlası.
Ne demek istiyorum? Mesela;
şimdi hepimizin;
bir başka hayatları daha var,
paralel evrenler icat ettik.
Kuantum fiziğini falan kastetmiyorum.
Yav şimdi hepimiz burada bir hayatın
akışını birlikte paylaşıyoruz,
aynı anda hepimizin
bir Twitter hayatı var, bir Facebook
hayatı var, bir Instagram hayatı var.
Ne bileyim böyle bir taraftan
aklınız burada
bir taraftan -bütün dost
sohbetlerinde olduğu gibi-üç dakika sonra,
acaba yeni mention var mı?
Facebook'da ne kaçırıyorum?
Instagram'da kaç like aldım?
Aa şu an canlı yayında
evlilik programlarında
kim kime evlilik teklif etti?
Orada bir dünya akıyor, orada bir hayat.
Sinemalar var, bir sürü
gidemediğimiz filmler.
Okumadığımız, okuyamadığımız
bir sürü kitaplar çıkıyor şuan.
İnternet artık haberler canlı,
neyi kaçırıyoruz acaba?
Şimdi çok şey yaşamak
isteyen insan ne oldu?
Çok şey yaşamak isterken
hiçbirine yetişemeyen
ve kaçırma kaygısıyla dolu bir
insan haline dönüştü.
Kaygılanıyoruz, yani
hız bizi kaygılandırıyor.
Çok şey yaşama arzusu
bizi kaygılandırıyor.
Hiçbir işe yaramadı kaygılandık.
Üçüncü bir şey daha;
hayatın kısa olduğunu,
ölümlü olduğunu bilen bir canlı,
hayatına bir anlam arıyor.
Yani nefes almak yetmiyor.
Hayatın kendisi bizzat anlamlı gelmiyor.
Bize bunu iten bir şey
anlamlı olamaz falan gibi.
Yine, bir kediye sorsak,
dile gelse, ki zaman zaman geliyor
kedi anne dedi gibi şeyler.
Dile gelse kediye hayatın anlamını sorsak,
bir kedi için hayatın anlamı hayattır ya.
Yaşamın anlamı yaşamaktır.
Sincaba sorsak, yaşamaktır.
Sincabın bir kariyer planı yok,
daha çok ceviz kırayım,
(Gülüşmeler)
ceviz kırmayı gerçek anlamda kullandım.
Efendim kariyer yapayım, ceviz
kırma yüksek okuluna gideyim yok.
Bir tek insan bir anlam yüklemeyi,
yeni bir anlam yüklemek çabasına giriyor.
Oysa diyorum ya;
hayatın kendisi bir mucize.
Ama fark edemiyor bir anlam
aramaya kalkışıyor.
Bulduğu anlamlarda ne,
şöyle özetliyeyim;
hep sahip olmak üzerine,
hayatına bir anlam katmak için
bir meslek sahibi olmak istiyor.
Bir ünvan sahibi olmak istiyor.
Efendim bir yuva sahibi, bir eş sahibi,
bir evlat sahibi olmak,
bir servet sahibi olmak,
bir imaj sahibi olmak,
bir ideoloji sahibi olmak.
Hep sahip olmak, sahip olmak,
sahip olma kaygısı.
Olabilecek miyim? Olacak mıyım falan.
Olduktan sonra da onu koruma kaygısı,
onu koruma kaygısı ah elimden kaçmasın,
elimden kaçmasın.
Kaygı, kaygı, kaygı...
Bakar mısınız ne oldu?
Belki daha vardır.
Üç tanesini falan anlattım; kısa ömründe
çok şey yaşamak isteyen insan, rezanın
çok şey yaşamak istediği anlam
yüklemeye çalıştı, eline ne geçti?
Kaygı.
İnsan; %75'i sudan, %100'ü kaygıdan
oluşan bir canlıya dönüştü.
Kaygılandığınızı görüyorum.
Dinleyiciye iyi gelmedi dediklerim.
Şimdi önereceğim çözüm önerimi
kendimce söyleyeyim.
Ne yapacağız peki bu kaygıdan
kurtulup mutlu olmak için?
Ne yapacağız?
Bir; arkadaşlar, seçmeyi öğreneceğiz.
Yani diyelim bütün filmlere
gitmek istiyoruz,
kaçırıyoruz ve kaygılanıyoruz ya;
hangi filmin kötü olduğunu bilirsek
hem iyi filme gideriz,
hem de o kaçırdığımız kötü
filmlere üzülmeyiz.
Ya da iyi gittiğimiz film bu ne biçim film
hayatım mahvoldu demeyiz.
Aynı şey kitap için geçerli, aynı şey
açık büfe içinde geçerli.
Değil mi ya bu seçmeyi
öğrenmemiz lazım.
Seçmeyi öğrenmek içinde kültür lazım.
Kültür lazım. Şöyle diyorum;
para kazanmak için kültür gerekmez
ama parayı harcamak için
kültür lazım arkadaşlar.
(Alkışlar)
İnan bak kültür deyince
herkes korkuyor deminden beri.
Mesela, yemek kültürünü kast ediyorum.
Sen açık büfeye gittiğinde hangisini
yesem diye kaygılanacağına,
ya bunu aldık kötü mü ettik?
Onu da kaçırdım eyvah!
Yiyeceğin üç tabak, doksan yedi tabak
lan yiyemiyorum diye kahrediyorsun,
onunda tadını çıkartamıyorsun.
Yav ama bir damak kültürün,
yemek kültürün olursa
-benim damak zevkime uygun değil,
bunları istemiyorum,
yiyeceğimde üç tas yemek,
bunları yiyorum dersin.
Hem onları yediğin
iyi yemek yediğin için üzülmezsin,
hem onları kaçırdığın için üzülmezsin.
Tekrar ettim ama ya seçmeyi öğrenmek
lazım bunun içinde kültür lazım.
İki; arkadaşlar,aslında ihtiyacımız olan
her şey kendi içimizde var inanın.
İhtiyacımız olan her şey
kendi içimizde var.
Ne demek istiyorum?
Bir atasözü var; tırnak kaşınan yeri
bilir arkadaşlar.
Hakikaten şu an bir yeri kaşınan varsa
lütfen kaşır mı? Bir görmek istiyorum.
Işıkları da açalım, gerçekten
hocam, hocam, hocam...
Benim buram gerçekten kaşındı, buram.
Arkadaşlar, bakın buram kaşındı,
belki göremediğim yerlerini
kaşıyan da olmuştur.
Parmağımda GPRS olmadan,
Google Haritayı açmadan,
Yandexlemeden, bir arkadaşına
sormadan, kaşınan yeri buldu.
Bir örnek daha vereceğim:
Bebekler, el kadar bebek,
daha yürümeyi bilmiyor emekliyor.
Okumayı, konuşmayı nereden bilsin?
Bir mineral eksikse kum yiyor.
Eskiden götürüyorlardı,
çocuğum kum yiyor diyor diye.
Doktor, test yapmadan -doğru
mineral eksikliği var, diyordu.
Ulan el kadar bebek tıp okumadı,
uzmanlık yapmadı,
doktorun bildiğini nereden biliyor?
İçinde var.
Bunla ilgili çok örnekler var,
bir deneyde var.
Uzatmak istemiyorum.
Hepimiz, canım çekti diyoruz ya
eğer dış uyaranlar olmazsa
o canınız çektiğiniz şey,
canımız çekti dediğimiz şey
vücudunuzun ihtiyacı.
C vitamini eksikse portakal çekiyor.
Deneyler var. Araştırın ya da
bana itimat edin bu böyle.
Peki niye böyle oluyor?
Madem içimizde
ihtiyacımız olan her şey
içimizde var, her bilgi içimizde var.
Niye dinleyemiyoruz?
Doğru seçimler yapamıyoruz?
Çünkü arkadaşlar, çok fazla dış ses var.
O dış ses, içimizden gelen sesi
bastırıyor ve baskınlıyor.
Sadece bastırmıyor,
baskıcı bir dış ses var.
Çok örnekleri var; bir tanesi reklamlar,
bir tanesi el alem ne der,
cümlesinde geçen el alem.
İyi niyetli doğru saydığımız babamız,
iyi niyetli doğru söyleyen
öğretmenlerimiz,
şunlar bunlar reklamlara geleyim.
En çarpıcı örnek;
şimdi, üniversitede reklam teorisi
diye bir ders okudum.
İlk dersin ilk cümlesi; kitaptaki
ilk cümle aklımdan çıkmıyor.
Reklamın amacı; tüketicinin,
ihtiyaç sıralamasını değiştirmek.
Çok ağır konuşuyor kavgada söylenmez o.
(Gülüşmeler)
Tekrar ediyorum, reklamın amacı;
tüketicinin, ihtiyaç
sıralamasını değiştirmektir.
Gerekirse yeni ihtiyaçlar yaratmaktır.
Şimdi anladınız mı ne demek istediğimi?
Yani, sizin gerçek ihtiyacınız olmayanı
bazı dış sesler ihtiyacın var diye
sizi şartlıyor, o yüzden içinizdeki
gerçek iç sesinizi duyamıyorsunuz.
Ne olur? Şimdi bunun farkında olup
bir rahatlama hissedeceksiniz.
Ve bazen şimdi hayata
anlam katmak diyoruz ya.
Ne oluyor, hayata anlam katmak?
Bir an mesela bir ayakkabıyı alamıyorsun,
alamadığın için hayatın anlamı
o oluyor çünkü sadece
onu düşünüyorsun. Alıyorsun gözün
vitrindeki bir başka şeye takılıyor.
Çünkü gerçek ihtiyacın değil.
Ya da alamıyorsun
maaşın yetmiyor, üzülüyorsun.
Üzülme canım kardeşim ya.
O senin gerçek ihtiyacın değil işte!
Okulunu okudum diyorum, itimat edin.
Reklamcıların, dış sesi dediğim
eğitimlerden bu dış sesler
çok fazla var.
Yani; şimdi ne yapacağız?
İç sesimiz her şeyi söylüyor içimizde
var ihtiyacımız olan
ama başta reklamlarda her türlü
yumuşak ya da sert otorite,
dış sesiyle bizi baskılıyor ne yapacağız?
Abi, içinizden -bir de
toplumda da yaşıyoruz-
gelenekler, görenekler, kültürler var.
İçimizden gelen her şeyi yapamayız
biliyorum gerçekçi bir adamım aslında.
İçinden gelen bir şeyi yapamıyorsan,
hiç değilse içinden gelmeyeni yapma.
Anlatabildim mi?
Özgürlüğün pek çok tanımı var.
Bir tanede özgür, sevdiğim bir tanesi;
özgürlük, insanın canının her
istediğini yapması değil,
eğer istemediğin bir şeyi
yapmıyorsan özgürsün.
Anlatabiliyor muyum?
Hiç değilse içinizden gelmeyeni yapmayın.
İçinizden gelmeyeni yapmayın.
Size, bir tane çok güzel
sizi iyi hissettirecek,
bu dış ses iç ses kavramını,
ayrımını yapabilmek için
efendim gerçek ihtiyacım mı
anlayabilmek için,
istemediğiniz bir durumla
karşılaştığınızda,
sadece şunu söyleyin;
sihirli iki cümleyi söylüyorum.
İçinizden, mecbur muyum?
Bir düşünün bak ayırt etmenize
çok yardımcı olacak.
Ben bu adama mecbur muyum?
Ben bu kadına mecbur muyum?
Ben bu ayakkabıyı alamadım
diye üzülüyorum,
almaya mecbur muyum?
Ben bu patrona mecbur muyum?
Ya da ben bu elemana mecbur muyum?
Çok rahatlatacak sizi, inanın
bir ayırt edeceksiniz
gerçekten ihtiyacın olan ile olamayanı.
Ama bakın tek başına çok terapik
bir etkisi de var bak
test edelim, deneyelim.
Bak şöyle, içinizden edin; ben insanım
hiç bir şeye mecbur değilim.
Çok rahatlatacak, beraber söyleyelim mi?
İçinizden söylediniz mi?
Rahatladınız mı?
Bakın bir daha,
hiçbir şeye mecbur değilim.
Hiçbir şeye mecbur değilim.
(Seyirciler)
Ben insanım, hiçbir şeye mecbur değilim.
Rahatladık mı?
(Alkışlar)